[Music]
so I'd like to share a little bit how I
got here today I had to set up an alarm
at 5:30
I had to snooze it several times before
I woke up after that I took my dog for a
walk and I liked to listen to some music
while I do this huge transplant by the
way after I finished walking my dog I
had to check my calendar
so I know exactly where I need to be so
I don't go under on stage and lastly I
had to check my bus schedule and I
realized I was late so I ran it real
fast and I made it it's funny my wife
still thinks I'm a runner and actually I
am I run every day to catch the bus good
morning everyone my name is Charmaine de
Silva and I'm a product manager on
Android like sweat I spend my days
running to meetings some days I get to
travel to meet all of you
and find my way through new cities and
after all the excitement of my days I
get to say good night to my boys before
I end my day with my favorite TV shows
of course my favorite TV shows how
dragons these days now possible to think
about both our stories you must have
guessed by now that all of this was
achieved on our smartphones but our
stories are in no way unique every day
billions of people around the world use
the applications that you have built to
connect with people around the world and
do incredible things however our users
tell us that they want more transparency
and control over their data they expect
Android as a platform to give them tools
for that transparency and control this
responsibility to our users is something
that have all taken very seriously and
that's why we're here today we're here
to talk to you about the new privacy
features in
Android q and how you can leverage them
to build privacy forward apps over the
years Android has matured we've added a
wide range of features to protect our
users like file based encryption runtime
permissions log download Google protect
and anymore on Android we embrace
privacy is a way to innovate an Android
has always been designed with security
and privacy at its core in Android q we
wanted to go farther we added almost 50
features related to privacy and security
so these features are designed to
provide more protection user control and
transparency to develop these features
we worked very closely with many of them
we shared our ideas our designs our
prototypes we heard your feedback and we
embedded this back into our products we
couldn't have done this without you so
thank you all so much
Astrid mentioned you spent countless of
art with us through workshops filing
bugs and testing our betas helping us
understand the issues you face and
enabling us to serve you better we will
continue to build apps that matter none
of this could have been possible without
all of y'all thank you all for your
support we're so grateful to have
developers like you helped us build a
better platform so now we want to help
you build privacy first apps that you
like your users through the rest of this
journey we will share with you best
practices and introduce you to the new
features in Android Q let's get started
so starting with permissions
as you already know applications running
their own sandboxes so your application
to access user data needs to request
specific permissions in hundred 6.0 we
introduced the concept of runtime
permissions this allows your application
at runtime to prompt the user practicing
private data and the user can choose to
deny or approve the request
Astrid mentioned users have the ability
to approve or deny requests we're always
curious to understand what users do with
our devices when we survey our users to
understand why they actually deny
permission these are the top three
reasons we see one the app should not
need the permission to they expect the
app to still work without the permission
and three they feel like they can grant
permission later all of this tells us
one things users who deny permissions do
not understand the value when the app is
asking for it with this in mind let's
talk about how best to deal with the
permissions
okay step 1 determine if there are all
turned api's to give you the data that
you need if they are alternative api's
choose to use them instead of asking for
a permission alternate API is tend to be
narrow in scope which makes them a
better privacy choice let's go through a
few examples let's assume your app needs
to do SMS verification instead of asking
for the SMS runtime permission you can
instead use the SMS retriever API SMS
verification is a common use case for
which developers ask for the SMS
permission fortunately Google Play
Services has dedicated API for exactly
this uses the entry point is the SMS
retriever client and the main method is
start SMS retriever here's another
example what if your app need to know if
the user was in a phone call instead of
asking for the read phone state
permission you can instead call the
focus API to seek Allstate detecting the
whether the user is in a phone call is
the common reasons apps are asking for
the phone permission but there is a
better way you can use the audio focus
API if the user is currently in a phone
call
you will need not be able to gain audio
focus all you need to remember is to use
the audio manager compact and request
audio focus method last example what if
your app needs access to external
storage you do not necessarily need to
ask for the read external storage
permission you can instead leverage your
apps private app storage or use a system
file picker apps often request a storage
permission without taking advantage of
their dedicated folder on external
storage which does not require holding
the read and write storage permission
the way get this folder you say can't
you call contacts contacts get external
files there also the system provides
ways for you to bring trusted system UI
for the user to pick a file or directory
so you can work with it the way can
bring the file chooser UI is to fire the
action open document and the way to
bring the UI to pick a folder is to fire
the action open document tree these are
just a few examples how you can use
api's without asking for permissions to
provide better user experience please go
to the Android developer website to
learn more
ok so now you've done your research and
realize that are no alternative API is
to give you the data that you need you
now add step to determining the scope
for the permission and how you'd ask for
it in speaking to many developers like
yourself y'all believe that you will get
higher acceptance rate if you ask for
permissions up front however when we
pull our users we see that only 18% of
users except every permission of their
device most users make delivery choices
now that they think about it I'm one of
those people
always approves permissions but if I
think a little bit more I do it only if
I understand the use case and there is
an immediate value for me as a user if I
grant their permission as switch
experience is not like unlike our users
when we ask a user why they choose to
give an app access to permission the top
reason they say is because they want you
to use a specific feature of an app this
tells us that they were intentional with
their choice users are more likely to
give your app access to your permission
if they understand the purpose and the
perceived benefit feels logical let's go
through four examples of where the
benefit of the random permission is very
clear so if if the context is clear ask
for a permission directly and this way
user will know exactly why the
permission is needed
they have context there is an immediate
value for the user and there is a higher
probability of user granting the
permission to the application just using
your feature for example if you're in
the chat application and you want to
share photos and you click the camera
button the user will not be surprised if
they're asked for the camera permission
and they will probably grant you the
permission because they want to use your
feature so in this scenario let's sweat
ran you through the use case is pretty
obvious but that's not always the case
there are situations where you need to
educate the user of your feature benefit
before the runtime prompt is shown it's
better to present the views case right
before the runtime prompt here's an
example from Ness HomeAway assist
feature this dialog precedes the
location runtime prompt in Android P
this is what the location runtime prompt
looks like the user choice is binary
users can choose to either approve or
deny the location request if we user
provides location permission to an app
the Akrid now access location in the
foreground or in the background in
Android q introducing more granular
control
to the app users can give to a gifted
app the choice to have only four grand
access to the location or foreground and
background access to location as an app
developer only ask for background app
access if you only have a clear need for
it now that the location permission can
be requested well in Access and all the
time
you need to choose the right scope that
best fits your feature our
recommendation is when whenever possible
use well in used locations the way you
ask for well the news location is
exactly the same you ask for location as
always you ask for that course or fine
location permission however if you want
to access location in the background you
need to add an additional modifier
permission called access background
location so this permission needs to be
combined with the existing final course
location permissions and this is a
signal to the platform to show you why
to the user where they have choices
between wolly news all the time and the
united requests scope is also relevant
to storage in android q we are in the
concept of scoped storage scope storage
provides better application data's of
isolation and also protects the
collections of videos and audio later
today we have another talk which goes
very like in details and please attend
us okay so now at this point you've got
your apps get runtime permissions you
now have a responsibility to user data
step 3 ensure users are not surprised
with your data usage here are some best
practices one collect only the data that
you need to only share the data once you
get explicit user consent 3 if you're
transferring data off the device ensure
that it is encrypted and secure for
only keep data for as long as you need
it by following these best practices
your users are feeling more comfortable
with how their data is being used by
your application now this concludes our
section on permissions let's talk to
other areas in Android q now that you've
finished with permissions another area
we focused our attention was device
identifiers in Android cube
we're logging down harder based device
identifiers so instead you need to
instead of hardware device identifiers
you need to use software based user
resettable device identifiers this is
much more privacy friendly solution we
also randomizing mac address this
feature shipped in android be as
experimental feature under developer
options where we use different random
MAC address when we can when the device
connects to different networks now we
bring in this feature main stream
available to all apps all the time
another area we focused on was app
launching in notifications this area is
important to build user trusts that
users feel like they're in control of
their device apps launch into the
foreground can sometimes feel intrusive
and disruptive to the user experience
notification API is can be used to
notify the users without interrupting
the user flow there are two main
benefits one the users maintain context
and to do not disturb rules are actually
maintained for cases of alarms and
incoming calls you can ensure a full
screen experience when the device is
locked or a heads of notification like
in this example when the device is in
use this avoids completely interrupting
the user so it will explain to you how
you can implement this in your app so
the recommended way to involve the user
is to use the notification API you're
all familiar with the only thing to
remember is the set full screen intent
API which allows you to set an intent
which will be fired off if the user is
not actively using the device so if the
device is locked the user will see a
full screen experience if the user is
currently using the device they will see
the heads-up notifications Sharman
mentioned and this will not interrupt
user flow while still letting the user
know there is something requiring their
attention in android q background app
launching will be blocked apps will no
longer be able to launch themselves from
the background to the foreground this
ensures that users are appropriately
interrupted and respects their context
and do not disturb settings we're now on
our last leg of our journey foreground
services foreground services are a
lightweight way to run an application
when it is not visible in the foreground
but foreground services can be noisy try
to limit your use of foreground services
to tasks that are continuation of an
ongoing activity like navigation to
improve the user experience in android q
we're introducing the concept of service
types and will be limiting permission
usage based on the service type for
example if your application has while we
use location permission and you want to
use location in a foreground service you
need to annotate your service is being
location type the way you do this is
using the foreground service type
attribute in the declaration in the
manifest of your service and if you
don't do this you will not get location
delivered to your application in while
this service is running
so we've covered a lot of privacy
features and best practices and there is
a lot more you can learn on the Android
developer website if you want to learn
more about these features please attend
these other privacy sessions or come
talk to us in the sandbox thank you all
for joining us today and giving us this
opportunity to work together let's
continue the conversation and keep
building privacy forward apps thank you
all
[Music]
[Applause]